después de movimientos derechos civiles
nos dio esa sabiduría tiene a la gente
la luz ellos encontrarán la vida denle a
la gente la luz estas son palabras para
nuestro tiempo el presidente actual ha
dejado eeuu en la oscuridad por mucho
tiempo
mucha rabia mucho miedo mucha división
aquí y ahora les doy mi palabra si
ustedes me dan la confianza de la
presidencia buscaré lo mejor de nosotros
no lo peor sería un aliado de la luz no
de la oscuridad es tiempo para que
nosotros el pueblo nos unamos y no se
equivoquen unidos podemos y superaremos
esta temporada de oscuridad en estos
estados
escogeremos la esperanza los hechos soy
un demócrata orgulloso que estaré
orgulloso de llevar la bandera de
nuestro partido de la elección general
así que es un gran honor
humildad que acepto esta nominación para
presidente de los eeuu de américa
pero mientras seré un candidato
demócrata seré un presidente
estadounidense trabajaré duro por
aquellos que no me apoyaron tan duro por
ellos como lo hice o lo haré por
aquellos que sí votaron por mí ese es el
trabajo de un presidente representar a
todos nosotros no solamente a nuestra
base oa nuestro partido este no es un
momento partidista este debe ser un
momento estadounidense es un momento con
una causa por la esperanza por nuestro
futuro con luz para ver el futuro y con
amor unos por otros
eeuu no solamente una colección de
intereses que chocan o de estados azules
o rojos somos mucho más grandes que eso
somos mucho mejores que eso hace casi un
siglo
roosevelt hizo unión en un momento de
gran incertidumbre de desempleo y miedo
golpeado por una enfermedad por un virus
dijo que iba a recuperar y triunfar
pensaba que había que eeuu lo haría y lo
hizo y nosotros podemos hacerlo
igualmente esta campaña no se trata sólo
de ganar votos se trata de ganar los
corazones y si el alma de los eeuu
ganarla por los generosos no por los
egoístas por los trabajadores que
mantienen a este país andando no
solamente los privilegiados que están
arriba por aquellos en esas comunidades
que han conocido las injusticias de una
rodilla en el cuello por esas personas
que ven cómo se reducen las
oportunidades ellos merecen la
experiencia de la promesa estadounidense
merecen experimentar de manera total
ninguna generación sabe lo que se les va
a pedir todo lo que podemos saber es si
estamos listos cuando llega a ese
momento y ahora la historia nos ha
entregado uno de los momentos más
difíciles que eeuu haya enfrentado jamás
cuatro crisis históricas todos al mismo
tiempo
una tormenta perfecta la peor pandemia
en más de 100 años la peor crisis
económica desde la gran depresión el
llamado a una justicia racial desde los
60s y las realidades y las amenazas
crecientes del cambio climático entonces
la pregunta para nosotros es la
siguiente estamos listos yo creo que sí
tenemos que estarlo todas las elecciones
son importantes pero sabemos que esta es
mucho más importante como muchos han
dicho estamos en un punto de inflexión
estamos en un momento de peligro pero
también de una posibilidad
extraordinaria podemos tomar el camino
de volvernos
más divididos y llenos de rabia un
camino de sombras y división y sospecha
o encontrar un camino distinto y dos
juntos tomar esta opción de cambiar de
reformar de unir un camino de esperanza
y de luz este es una dirección que
cambiará una vida esto determinará cómo
se verá a eeuu durante mucho mucho
tiempo el carácter está ahí dices la
decencia es lo que tienen que escoger la
ciencia la democracia todo está en la
elección
quiénes somos como nación que defendemos
y lo más importante quienes queremos ser
todo eso es lo que está en la elección
la elección no podría ser más clara no
se necesita retórica
simplemente juzguen a este presidente
por los hechos 5 millones de
estadounidenses con 19 más de 170 mil
muertos de lejos mejor perfomance de
ninguna nación en la tierra
más de 50 millones de personas que han
pedido subsidios de desempleo más de 10
millones de personas que van a perder su
seguro de salud este año
uno de cada seis negocios han salvado
este año y este presidente difícil si es
reelecto saben lo que va a ocurrir los
casos y las muertes se mantendrán muy
altas más negocios tradicionales van a
cerrar y esta vez para siempre las
familias trabajadores van a luchar y
tener problemas para salir adelante y el
1% obtendrá miles de millones de dólares
en nuevos recortes fiscales y el ataque
a la forma volcker continuará hasta que
quede destruido quitándole el seguro de
salud a más de 20 millones de personas
incluyendo más de 15 millones que
dependen del medicaid y acabar con las
protecciones que el presidente obama
trabajo tan duro para aprobar y para
personas
y que tienen condiciones preexistentes y
hablando del presidente obama fue un
honor servir junto a él como su
vicepresidente de gm tomar este momento
para decir algo que casi no decimos
gracias señor presidente usted fue un
gran presidente un presidente que
nuestros hijos podían admirar nadie va a
decir eso de la persona que ocupa la
casa blanca lo que sabemos de este
presidente es que si te dan cuatro años
más será lo que ha sido por estos cuatro
años un presidente que no toma
responsabilidad que se rehúsa a liderar
qué culpa a otros que se acerca a los
dictadores y que aviva las llamas del
odio y la diversión se despertará cada
día creyendo que ese trabajo se trata de
él y nunca de ustedes
ese es el país que quieren para ustedes
para sus familias para sus hijos
yo veo en eeuu distintos uno que es
generoso y fuerte
que es humilde uno que podemos
reconstruir juntos como presidente el
primer paso que tomaré será controlar el
virus que ha acabado con tantas vidas
porque hay que entender algo que el
presidente no ha entendido nunca vamos a
recuperar la economía nunca haremos que
nuestros niños regresen de manera segura
a las escuelas nunca tendremos nuestra
vida de vuelta hasta que nos enfrentemos
a este virus
la tragedia dónde estamos hoy es que no
tenía que ser así
simplemente miren alrededor no es así en
canadá o en europa o en japón o
prácticamente ninguna otra parte del
mundo y el presidente sigue diciéndonos
que el virus va a desaparecer está
esperando un milagro bueno tengo
noticias para él es ningún milagro
llegará
lideramos el mundo en casos confirmados
en muertes nuestra economía está
destruida donde los asiáticos latinos y
los afroamericanos llevan lo peor de
esto y después de todo este tiempo el
presidente aún no tiene un plan pues yo
sí lo tengo si soy su presidente desde
el día 1 vamos a implementar una
estrategia nacional que yo he estado
presentando desde marzo vamos a
desarrollar y desplegar pruebas rápidas
con resultados inmediatos haremos que
los suministros médicos y los equipos de
protección que necesita el país
los construiremos aquí en el país para
que nunca más estemos a la merced de
china o algún otro país extranjero para
proteger a nuestra propia gente nunca
nos aseguraremos que las escuelas tengan
los recursos necesarios para abrir de
manera segura y efectiva
pondremos la política del lado
dejaremos que los expertos hablen para
que la gente pueda obtener la
información que merece y necesita una
verdad honesta y clara que ellos pueden
soportar tendremos un mandato nacional
para portar máscaras no como un peso
sino como un deber patriótico para
protegernos unos a otros y asegurarnos
que haremos lo que debimos haber hecho
desde el principio nuestro presidente
actual ha fallado y ha fracasado en su
nación más básica con la nación ha
fracasado a la hora de protegernos a la
hora de proteger a eeuu y queridos
estadounidenses eso es algo imperdonable
como presidente les hago una promesa
protegeré a eeuu nos defenderemos de
cualquier ataque que podamos pero no
siempre sin excepción cada vez
miren yo comprendo comprendo lo difícil
que es tener esperanza en este momento
en esta noche de verano déjeme tomar un
momento para hablar a ustedes que han
perdido a alguien yo sé lo que eso se
siente perder a alguien que has amado sé
y conozco ese hoyo negro que sientes en
el pecho que parece que te estuviera
succionando y es algo doloroso cruel e
injusto como la vida puede ser a veces
pero he aprendido dos cosas
lo primero es tu ser amado puede haber
seguido de la tierra pero nunca se irá
de tu corazón siempre estarán contigo
siempre los escucharás
y segundo he encontrado a través de la
pérdida del dolor que lo mejor es
encontrar un propósito
y como hijos de dios todos tenemos un
propósito en la vida tenemos un gran
propósito como nación
abrir las puertas de la oportunidad para
todos
para salvar nuestra democracia ser una
luz para el mundo nuevamente y
finalmente hacer respetar las palabras
del documento sagrado que fundó esta
nación que todos los hombres y mujeres
son creados iguales
dados por su creador con algunos
derechos inalienables entre ellos la
vida la libertad y la búsqueda de la
felicidad
mi padre era un hombre decente se cayó
varias veces pero siempre se levantó
trabajo duro y construyó una maravillosa
vida de clase media para nuestra familia
me decía yo hoy yo no espero que el
gobierno resuelva mis problemas pero
claramente espero que los entienda y
después de un trabajo se trata de mucho
más que un cheque se trata de tu
dignidad se trata de el respeto se trata
de tu lugar en la comunidad se trata de
ser capaz de decirle a tu hija ya tu
esposa las cosas van a estar bien y
decirlo de manera sincera nunca olvidaré
esas lecciones es por eso que mi plan
económico se trata de empleos de
dignidad de respeto y de comunidad y
juntos podemos y vamos a reconstruir
esta economía y cuando lo hagamos no
solamente vamos a construir sino a
reconstruir mejor con rutas modernas con
banda ancha puertas aeropuertos como una
nueva fundación a nuevo
para el crecimiento con agua limpia para
cada comunidad con 5 millones de empleos
para que el futuro sea hecho en eeuu con
el sistema de salud con los deducibles
más bajos
construyendo sobre la foto cara que le
está tratando de destruir con un sistema
de educación que entrene a la gente para
los mejores trabajos del siglo 21 no hay
nada de eso que los trabajadores de este
país no puedan hacer y cuyo costo no
evite que la gente vaya a la universidad
y que sean aplastados por la deuda
cuando salgan de ahí con un sistema de
cuidado infantil que sea y que haga
posible que los padres vayan a trabajar
y que los mayores puedan quedarse en
casa con dignidad con un sistema
migratorio que empodere a nuestros
nuestros valores y que los refleje y
también a los sindicatos porque son
ellos los que construyeron la clase
media con pago igualitario para las
mujeres
y salarios en aumento con los cuales
puedes cuidar y criar a una familia y si
vamos a hacer más que trabajar por estas
personas finalmente les vamos a pagar
haremos y trabajaremos para superar el
cambio climático que no solamente es una
crisis sino que es una oportunidad
enorme una oportunidad para que
lideremos el mundo en energía limpia y
creemos millones de nuevos trabajos que
paguen bien en el proceso y podemos
pagar por estas inversiones acabando con
esas brechas y los recortes impuestos
que el presidente ha dado al 1% y a las
grandes corporaciones algunas de las
cuales ni siquiera pagan impuestos para
nada porque no necesitamos un código
fiscal
[Música]
que premia la riqueza más de lo que
premia el trabajo no quiero castigar a
nadie lejos de eso pero ya ha pasado
mucho tiempo de que las personas más
ricas y las grandes corporaciones de
este país paguen su parte justa y para
las personas de la tercera edad la
seguridad social es una obligación
sagrada una promesa sagrada hecha por la
cual pagaron el presidente actual quiere
romper esa promesa ha propuesto eliminar
un impuesto que paga por la mitad de la
seguridad social sin ninguna manera de
acabo de devolver ese ingreso faltante
yo no voy a permitir que eso ocurra si
soy su presidente vamos a proteger la
seguridad social y medicare ustedes
tienen mi palabra
una de las voces más poderosas que hemos
escuchado en el país y que escuchamos es
de la gente joven están hablando sobre
la injusticia y la inequidad que está
creciendo en el país la injusticia
racial económica medioambiental yo
escucho sus voces y sé que ustedes
pueden escucharlas también está amenaza
existencial que representa el cambio
climático
el miedo de recibir un disparo en una
escuela o cuando estás en tu primer
trabajo será el trabajo del próximo
presidente restaurar la promesa
estadounidense para todos y no tendré
que hacerlo solo porque tendré a una
gran vicepresidenta a mi lado
la senadora kamala harris es una voz
poderosa para esta nación su historia es
la historia estadounidense si ella
conoce los obstáculos
que han enfrentado tantas personas las
mujeres las mujeres negras los asiáticos
los inmigrantes los que se han quedado
atrás
pero ella ha superado cada uno de esos
obstáculos que han enfrentado y nadie ha
sido más rudo con los grandes bancos y
el lobby armamentístico nadie ha sido
más rudo atacando a la administración
por su extremismo y su fracaso a la hora
de seguir la ley y decir la verdad
y yo venimos de familias y de ahí
tenemos nuestra fortaleza hay estados y
su familia para mí es tío y la nuestra
he dicho muchas veces que ningún hombre
merece un gran amor y mucho menos dos
pero yo he conocido a dos después de
perder a mi esposa en ese accidente
llegó a mi vida
ella reconstruyó nuestras familias es
una educadora una madre una madre mil
grandes y una fuerza que no se puede
parar
si ella pone su mente en algo
simplemente quítate porque ella lo hará
lo cumplirá será fue una gran segunda
dama y sé que será una gran primera dama
para esta nación porque ella ama tanto a
este país y siempre tendré la fortaleza
que solamente puede venir de la familia
ashley todas nuestras nietas mis
hermanos y hermanas me levantan me dan
coraje aunque ya no estén con nosotros
algunos de ellos wow me inspira todos
los días
bowes sirvió en el uniforme de esta
nación un año en irak y fue condecorado
como un veterano de esa guerra
entonces me tomó muy personalmente y
tengo una profunda responsabilidad de
servir como comandante en jefe seré un
presidente que esté con nuestros aliados
y nuestros amigos y les dejaremos claro
a los adversarios que los días de
acercarse a los dictadores se acabó
bajo el presidente de byd en eeuu no
dará la espalda a las recompensas
por los soldados estadounidenses ni
tampoco permitiremos interferencias en
el ejercicio democrático del voto
y siempre me levantaré por nuestros
valores de dignidad derechos humanos
trabajaré por un propósito común
para un mundo más próspero seguro y
pacífico la historia la historia
nos ha enviado una tarea urgente y
seremos nosotros la generación que
finalmente acabe con el racismo de
nuestro carácter nacional
yo creo que estamos enfrentándonos a eso
creo que estamos listos hace solamente
una semana ayer fue el tercer
aniversario de lo que ocurrió en
charleston cierre en sus ojos recuerden
lo que vieron en televisión
recuerden ver a esos neonazis y esos
supremacistas blancos saliendo de los
campos con antorchas en las manos con
las venas y escupiendo el mismo tipo de
antisemitismo que se excluía que se
escuchaba en europa en los años 30
recuerden ese choque de lo que ocurrió
después entre aquellos que expandían el
odio y aquellos que tuvieron el coraje
de enfrentarse a él
recuerden lo que dijo el presidente
cuando se le preguntó dijo que había
visitó personas muy buenas de ambos
lados eso fue un llamado a la conciencia
para nosotros como país y para mí un
llamado a la acción en ese momento yo
sabía que tenía que lanzarme la
presidencia como me lo enseñó mi padre
el silencio es complicidad si nunca pude
quedarme callado por complicidad en ese
momento dije que estábamos en la lucha
por el alma de esta nación y lo estamos
en una de las conversaciones más
importantes que he tenido en esta
campaña
fue con alguien que era demasiado joven
para votar
me reuní con jana floyd de 6 años el día
antes de que enterrar a su padre georg
floyd una niña increíblemente valiente
nunca olvidaré cuando me agaché hacia
ella para hablarle me miró a los ojos y
me dijo sí dando
mi papá cambio al mundo
mi papá cambió al mundo
sus palabras me llegaron a lo más
profundo del corazón tal vez el
asesinato de george floyd fue un punto
de inflexión tal vez yo santo y su
inspiración
pero sin importar como haya ocurrido
estamos listos para acabar con el peso
del odio por fin de una vez por todas
y después el trabajo duro y no bastan de
eliminar ese racismo sistémica
nos dicen que hemos pasado por los
momentos más oscuros donde hemos logrado
los mayores avances y ahí hemos
encontrado la luz y en este momento tan
oscuro creo que podemos hacer un gran
progreso nuevamente que podemos
finalmente encontrar la luz
saben muchas personas me han escuchado
decir que creo que se puede definir eeuu
en una sobre palabras posibilidades y es
lo que define a este país donde todo es
posible
y digo todos absolutamente todos
deberían recibir una oportunidad de ir
tan lejos como los lleven sus
habilidades y sus sueños nunca podemos
perder eso en tiempos que son tan
retadores como estos creo que solamente
hay una manera de avanzar como estados
unidos un país unido en la búsqueda de
una unión más perfecta unidos en nuestro
sueño de un mejor futuro para nosotros y
para nuestros hijos unidos en nuestra
determinación para hacer que los
próximos años sean brillantes están
listos yo creo que lo estamos esta es
una gran nación somos personas buenas y
decentes por el amor de dios
estos son los eeuu de américa nunca ha
habido nada
que no hayamos podido cumplir cuando lo
hacemos juntos
james y un poeta irlandés una vez dijo
la historia dice no esperes de este lado
de la tumba pero después una vez en la
vida la hora de la justicia puede
levantarse y puede rimar esta es la
manera de hacer que la esperanza y la
justicia arrimen con pasión y con
propósito ustedes y yo juntos una sola
nación bajo dios unidos en nuestro amor
por el país y por unos con otros porque
el amor es más poderoso que el odio y
que el miedo y también la luz es más
poderosa que la oscuridad es nuestro
momento es nuestra misión que la
historia pueda decir que al final de
este capítulo de la oscuridad comenzó
aquí esta noche
a medida que llegaban la luz la
esperanza uniéndose a la lucha por el
alma de la nación es uno
una batalla que ganaremos y lo haremos
juntos les prometo les prometo gracias y
que dios los bendiga y que dios proteja
a nuestras tropas